lyadona known as the weeping or wailing
woman was likely born in the 1650s we
know this because she appears to be in
her 20s when she is married with
children in 1673. la yadona was alive so
long ago that the best-known record of
her mostly comes from the folklore
surrounding her while the stories vary
depending on the source a few constants
overlap when layadona was young she had
a different name in some retellings it's
maria but in a well-known play written
in 1917 it's luisa in many iterations of
the story she was born into poverty but
as she grew up she became incredibly
beautiful so much so that she drew the
attention of a wealthy ranchero he
married her and they had two boys
unfortunately these children would not
live for very long as she gave them life
she also took it away thus beginning the
curse of lyodonna to find out what drove
this young mother to commit this act how
she became known as the weeping woman
and how her curse endangered generations
of children stick around to the end of
this video this video is sponsored by
audible
welcome to horror history in today's
lesson i'll be covering the life and
afterlife of one of mexico and central
america's most iconic legends la yarona
there's not a lot documented about the
childhood of wyodonia but one thing that
is consistent across the various legends
is that she grew up in poverty so when a
wealthy conquistador came to her town
and pursued her it makes sense that this
would be a very big deal to her
according to history today there was
initially a shortage of spanish women in
what the spanish dubbed as new spain the
region now referred to as spring break
this meant that unions between
indigenous women and spanish men were
quite common however many of these
unions didn't last very long to get a
better understanding we'll need to take
it back to mexico and parts of central
america during the 1600s where this
iteration of the legend originates
[Music]
the fates of indigenous and mestiza
women who married spaniards were mixed
some enjoyed stability and enhanced
status but more often than not they were
cast aside a few years later for younger
women or more often a spanish wife more
alarmingly their children were sometimes
taken away a practice that derived from
the spanish tradition of relieving the
so-called wayward women of their
children this left many women during
this time to feel completely helpless
lyadona is kind of an embodiment of the
collective pain and anger of women from
this time that got turned into legend
it's something that's come up a lot in
horror history from godzilla being a
metaphor for nuclear fallout to the
demogorgon being a manifestation of
fears of communism i think we need a
term for this so i'll call it cultural
legendizing that sounds pretty good
there are different iterations of la
llorona but for the sake of horror
history we'll stick to the lore as told
in the conjuring universe more
specifically the 2019 film the curse of
lyodonna according to the local priest
father perez the story goes as follows
lyadona fell in love and had two sons
with her husband the family loved each
other and her sons demonstrated their
care for her by giving her a necklace
i don't think she knew at the time how
literally true this statement was father
perez explains that she and her family
were happy until one day she found her
man in the arms of a younger woman in a
fit of rage she took away what he deemed
most valuable his testicles oh wait no
it was his children and she drowned them
in the nearby river as soon as her rage
blindness cleared and she realized what
she had done she weeped and then took
her own life in the same river cursing
herself to an eternity of trying to find
the souls of children to trade for her
own
children are told to behave
listen to their elders
allah your honor will come
and steal them away it kind of seems
like the moral of the story has been
aimed at the wrong people the kids are
the only people who didn't do anything
wrong and they suffered the most and
future generations of children are made
to fear the tale of la yadona when it
should probably be directed at couples
for the next 100 years lyadona continued
to haunt the river and other bodies of
water searching for children to kill as
the legend grew people claimed to hear a
woman crying some followed the sounds to
find a woman in a white gown floating
above the river if children were the
ones to find her she was said to be
ruthless and they wouldn't stand a
chance of escaping these stories mostly
come from mexico but like my friends at
the nearby taco truck the legend would
burrow its way across the border in 1973
the weeping woman appeared in los
angeles all this time i thought it was
la yadona maybe it's actually l.a yadona
it's never clearly explained how la yona
went from haunting one specific river in
mexico to becoming an angelino we just
know that she's doomed to an eternity of
searching rivers and bodies of water
there are several rivers such as the
colorado river or the tijuana river that
run from mexico into southern california
so over the course of 100 years she
could have migrated up these channels
while la yadona was just a children's
tale to some the single mother patricia
alvarez and the recent widow anna garcia
were about to experience the curse
firsthand i think la yadona targeted
these two women because they were
reminiscent of herself patricia is alone
in raising your kids and based on anna's
questions about if she started drinking
again it's clear that she's had a rough
life and doesn't really have a support
system anna lost her husband in the line
of fire and while he didn't choose to
leave her she was still left in a
difficult situation nonetheless both
patricia and anna have two children
close in age to la yadona's two kids and
both are hispanic lyodona first targets
patricia and her two sons carlos and
tomas patricia seems to take all the
necessary steps to deter the malicious
spirit a shrine of candles boarded up
windows religious iconography and a
closet transformed into a protective
spirit shelter for her kids she may have
set this up based on her own knowledge
of the legend of lyodona which she
demonstrates a pretty clear
understanding of
your children
have they heard her crying have they
felt the sting
of her tears
they will
soon
or she could have received guidance from
rafael a kurandero or healer who is an
expert at handling la yadona this might
explain why raphael is at the service
for her two boys after they're killed
and why he goes back later to collect a
sample of lyodona's tears either way
when anna arrives and finds that
patricia has hidden her children away
patricia begs anna for just one more
night which seems to imply that if
layadona isn't able to take the children
within a certain time frame she moves on
this could be representative of the
nature by which layadona kills her own
children it happened in a fit of rage
and once she had calmed down she
regretted her choice so maybe if given
enough time she'll spare the children
she's after just as she likely would
have with her own but that's just a
theory a film theo in the controvers
lyodonna does not just kill children
upon first sight her haunting follows a
specific process which we've seen before
her curse seems to follow the same rules
that apply to demonic possession by
following the steps of infestation
oppression and finally possession in la
yadona's case she isn't necessarily
trying to possess a person in the take
over their body sense that we're used to
seeing but she is trying to possess
children's souls in order to try to
bring her own children back to her it
makes sense that lyadona's curse follows
the same rules as demonic possession
just as bathsheba did with the parent
family back in 1971. bathsheba is not
technically a demon but the tereshi
dishes out follows the same process but
layadona's version of infestation
oppression and possession have unique
ways of manifesting themselves which
creates problems for all of those
involved
since i've already told you about ed and
lorraine warren's books that you can
listen to exclusively on audible there
are also many more reasons to explore
the catalog and sign up audible is the
only place you can listen to the
demonologist the career biography of ed
lorraine it's also the home of the
haunted house diaries where you can hear
about many more unexplainable details of
the farmhouse they investigated in the
original movie the conjuring movies can
only show you so much if you want to
know everything your ticket is audible
audible offers an incredible selection
of audiobooks across every genre
including lots of porn you'll also
discover exclusive audible originals
from top celebrities renowned experts
and exciting new voices in audio members
get a free title every month for keeps
plus there's a great selection of free
podcasts if you're new here welcome to
audible book club this month i'm
checking out to the grown up by jillian
flynn it's a short story by one of my
favorite authors she wrote gone girl and
sharp objects i thought i had read all
of her stuff so i was excited to find
this short story on audible to try out
audible premium plus free for 30 days
visit
audible.comworld or text cz's world to
500-500 you'll find that link in the
description audible.comworld
[Music]
lyodona's curse follows three specific
steps first she burns the children with
her tears by grabbing their arms and
scorching them by doing this she gains
access to them including the ability to
put them in a trance and lure them to
her this aspect of the legend would
reflect her own children's trust in her
before she drowned them with all of her
victims her method of attack is drowning
them in the nearest body of water the
location of the burn marks left on their
arms also ties back to the legend from
the 1600s the burns are in a very
visible spot and from what we can see
most or all of the families that are
spirit terrorizes are single mothers
children in single-parent households are
significantly more likely to be abused
according to this study in the national
library of medicine as i mentioned
patricia was already subject to welfare
checks before la irona entered her life
if abuse is founded during welfare check
law enforcement may take away the
children for their safety so the very
visible burn marks feel like lyodona's
revenge after her children were unfairly
taken from her she's imparting that same
pain onto her victims this is exactly
what happens to patricia keeping the
boys hidden away in the blessed closet
was her last hope at keeping carlos and
tomas safe from lyodona but during her
welfare check anna tries to take them
out leaving them completely vulnerable
as the boys sleep in the foster care
institution la yadona makes her next
move she puts domas in a trance and
summons him out of the bedroom carlos
wakes up and seeing his brother just
standing at the edge of the room runs
towards him trying to get him to come
back to bed but it's too late carlos
catches sight of la yadona in the mirror
then after her briefly disappearing he
gazes upon a puddle of water from a leak
in the ceiling and this happens
she grabs both of them and takes them to
a nearby river to drown them anna is
called to the crime scene to identify
the bodies and with no father to watch
them she has no choice but to take her
own children with and lock them in the
car stay in the car okay and please
don't wake up your sister but chris is a
kid and of course kids don't listen to
their parents especially when they're
right next to an active crime scene that
looks really cool patricia also shows up
and a driven mad with grief tries to
blame anna for interfering when anna
asks what she's talking about patricia
tells her
at this point patricia essentially
becomes a proxy of lyodona herself she's
prayed to the wicked spirit asking her
to take anna's children in place of her
own and i pray to her to give my
children back to me and take yours
instead patricia is now following
lyodonna's ghastly footsteps hoping to
sacrifice other children in order to
trade their souls for her own it's
almost as if the spirit of la yadona
sees anna's kids through patricia
because anna's kids aren't targeted
until patricia makes eye contact with
chris as she's taken away in the police
car when chris ignores his mother's
warning and gets out of the car to
investigate lyodona sobs in a nearby
alley luring chris to her sound as he
checks to see if she's okay her head
suddenly snaps in his direction and she
lunges towards him allowing herself to
burn him with her tears by grabbing his
arm and scorching it she's now attached
herself to the family she chases him
back to the car where he breaks the
other rule that anna set for him not to
wake up his sister as he begs to be let
back in only he can see la llerona
screeching at him on the other side of
the window but chris's behavior is still
enough to scare her in addition to that
samantha becomes lyodona's next target
the following day while anna is at work
she's playing out in the rain with a
see-through umbrella lyodona attempts to
lure her in the same way that she did
with chris by crying off in the distance
however sam has more self-preservation
and stops at the fence just at the end
of their yard so lyodona resorts to
other tactics she blows sam's umbrella
into the water and when she reaches in
to get it she's met with a surprise
she too is burned when lyodona grabs her
arm and scorches it with her tears that
night she puts chris into a heavy trance
and anna finds him repeatedly opening
and closing the front door she thinks
he's sleepwalking but he's really
setting the stage for la yadona to blow
open the door granting her access to the
house which she uses to confront anna
that same night get out of my house
[Applause]
anna ushers the kids to come in and
sleep in her bed while staying up all
night on guard with a baseball bat the
terror continues the next day while anna
is at work liadona lures chris into
samantha's bedroom and knocks him to the
floor with another powerful gust of
supernatural wind and lunges for him
scaring him away to the edge of the
stairs which she pushes him down after
appearing in the adjacent room he lands
on his wrist just before anna walks
through the door and she completely
overreacts considering from her point of
view he was just sitting there with a
sprained wrist
crash
sure layadona probably could have killed
chris right to then in there if she
wanted to but she may have been setting
anna up just like she did with patricia
to seem like an ill-equipped mother as
she would know firsthand that having her
own children taken away from her was a
pain worse than death the ensuing social
services visit at anna's house was
probably a humiliation very much akin to
lyodona's feelings when the conquistador
she married took her boys away to a
better suited woman also lyodonna still
needs to burn anna with the black tears
in order to complete the curse as
samantha is upstairs taking a bath alone
which seems like kinda not a good idea
given everything that has happened
lyodonna seizes the opportunity to
attack her and bring anna to a place of
vulnerability samantha is washing her
hair with her eyes closed when she feels
a pair of hands massaging her scalp for
a brief moment layadona is tender with
samantha just as she likely was with her
own children sam is tricked by the
feeling of that motherly touch however
as she leans her head back to rinse
layadonis decrepit hands pull her under
and pin her there anna and chris hear
the commotion in the bathroom and run up
to save her just in time anna pulls her
out of the tub where she crawls
backwards petrified in fear almost
looking as if she's scared of her mother
but she's actually gazing on to la
yadona this time it's anna's turn to get
burned by the weeping woman's touch just
as she turns around to see it by this
point lyodonna has marked each family
member to complete the curse and can now
strike at any moment to kill the
children things would be complicated
however when anna goes outside the
church to bring in reinforcements
[Music]
anna and the kids seek out the kurendera
raphael who reluctantly agrees and
implements his unorthodox methods by
having anna and his kids roll eggs over
everything in the house he calls the
ritual la limpa and he says that it's
meant to detect evil in the house the
ritual of rolling an egg in its shell to
pick up or ward off evil is a practice
that not only goes way back in mexican
healing but is still in practice today
he cracks one egg into a bowl revealing
the yolk to have turned into a burning
black tar and the other eggs explode
gushing the substance everywhere almost
like the spiritual equivalent of a paper
towel picking up dirt from a surface it
reveals that layadonna has definitely
made her mark on the house and the
family anna and the children assist
rafael and several other rituals leaving
the house looking very similar to how
patricia's looked when anna went to pay
her that initial welfare check while
doing this chris notices raphael's cross
which he explains to be crafted from the
fire trees that surround the river where
lyodona drowned her children
they say
the firing trees wept as liona drowned
her children as the only witness to her
sins they hold a special power over her
he also reveals the vial of lyodona's
black blood tears which he collected
from patricia's house he mixes it with
holy water and refers to it as
anti-venom lyodona arrives later that
night vicious and determines to find the
children anna and the kids believe that
they're being protected as they're
surrounded by candles huddled in the
living room under raphael's direction
but lyodona takes her by surprise and
wails out a horrible sound that
extinguishes all of the lights
and the kids are actually exactly where
lyodona wants them it wouldn't be a
movie in the conjureverse if there
weren't some aerating and lyodonna
starts that here anna is aerated out of
the way and left unconscious on the
floor as the kids beg raphael for help
he does nothing but instead slinks back
into the shadows of the house leaving
the kids unprotected and completely
susceptible to be irritated when anna
comes too she gets up to try to save her
son but she's not going to make it in
time at just the last possible moment
rafael sticks a hand out and grabs chris
while throwing his vial of antivenom
into lyodona's face this has the desired
effect and burns her face so badly that
she lets go of chris and rafael is able
to shove her out through the front door
he slams it shut and puts down another
row of seeds from the fire tree
explained another way it was all a setup
to lock la rona out of the house and to
her frustration she fell for it because
the seeds are collected from the same
fire tree that the cross is made from
lyodona is unable to cross this barrier
as long as the line is not broken and
apparently she can't use any of that
supernatural wind power to break them
herself i don't make the rules i guess
rafa overlooked the garcia's backdoor
though because lyodonna promptly uses
her force to blow it open anna chris and
raphael race back to steal it shut but
raphael was not the only one playing
chess here this was also just a clever
distraction clever girl she's really
just using the back door as a
distraction to trick samantha into
breaking the seal lyodona gets a hold of
misty samantha's beloved doll that she
associates with her deceased father she
would not be the first or last evil
entity to manipulate a doll in the
controvers misty is set outside just
barely out of samantha's reach so she'd
have to reach past the seeds to get it
it's also fitting that she uses this
doll named misty mist is the gaseous
form of water and water is lyodona's
murder weapon samantha takes the bait
and is just barely able to get misty
without breaking the line of seeds but
anna sees her at the last second and
yells at her to get away from the door
causing her to get distracted and
accidentally drag the doll through the
line of seeds granting layadona access
to the house lyodona immediately grabs
sam for one of the most dramatic air
eating sequences yet she takes her to
the nearest body of water at the
backyard pool and holds her under anna
dives in and feverishly searches with
the flashlight upon finding her at the
bottom lyodonna attacks anna and during
the scuffle anna rips off lyodona's
necklace the same necklace given to her
by her boys that she said she would wear
forever this absolutely enrages la
girona it's the last connection that she
has to her own children but before she
can retaliate raphael blesses the water
and mixes in salt causing the pool to be
turned into holy water which drives
lyodona out anna is able to rescue
samantha from drowning but samantha is
now in a trance just like what
patricia's son tomas experienced shortly
before his death rafael and anna
realized that the only way to keep
samantha from just walking outside into
lyodona's grasp again is that they must
keep her locked away the same method
that patricia was reprimanded for the
night of anna's visit so fittingly
patricia would be lyodona's last trump
card to weaponize against anna's family
being a regular corporeal human patricia
has no problem simply walking over the
fireseed barrier to abduct chris and
samantha you took my babies from me
she'll give them back to me patricia
shoots raphael on the shoulder and
breaks the line of seeds at the door
allowing laerona to get inside it isn't
completely clear if patricia entered
anna's house on her own volition or if
this was under lyonna's direction but in
either case we know she was manipulated
by her belief that her children's souls
could be freed if she offered the souls
of anna's children in their stead
lyadona after powering her way through
everyone in the house tosses anna into
the basement stairway as she is thrown
she drops lyodona's necklace but chris
picks it up and keeps it close at this
point the trans on samantha is broken
with no explanation as to why i would
speculate that it could be tied to the
sunrise as a symbol of the passage of
time into the next day again this goes
back to the idea that patricia brought
up at the beginning that she only needed
to keep her family safe a little bit
longer and then the evil would
potentially move on the children run to
the attic but the ball and broad finds
them and corners them as the final
moments draw near and she walks towards
them chris uses his final line of
defense lyodona's necklace this causes
her anger to suddenly disappear her face
returns to the soft kind features from
her natural life different people are
going to interpret this in different
ways but i think in that moment liodona
saw chris as one of her own children
offering the necklace and the anger and
malice temporarily went away allowing
her to take the appearance of a more
friendly ghost on the contrary you could
look at it as another one of her tricks
her trying to get the garcia children to
let their guard down the moment of
pleasantness would be short-lived
however as samantha accidentally
uncovers a mirror allowing la yadona to
see the reflection of her true monstrous
self eyes covered in black blood and she
immediately reverts to her previous form
the moment did buy chris and samantha
just enough time for anna and raphael to
reach the attic and protect them lyodona
turns her attention to raphael because
he poses the biggest threat with his
cross made from the fire tree seeds she
vehemently throws him into a pile of
boxes with all of the garcia family
together now she charges at them however
rafael is just able to kick his cross
across the room to anna he grabs it and
promptly stabs lyodona through the chest
and that would conclude the garcia
family's chapter with the malicious
central american legend however this may
not be the final chapter of her story
after anna and the kids say goodbye to
raphael later that morning she looks
back at a puddle and sees something that
alarms her while we hear the sounds of
children's laughter
could this be the return of lyodonna who
is always associated with water or does
this youthful laughter suggest that a
new entity perhaps one of her victims
has legendized as a new threat joining
the likes of bathsheba malthus valach
and isla among many other evil beings in
the controvers there is a lot more to
learn here about these antagonists so
check out the playlist on the left for
the lowdown on the controversy's most
horrifying villains and remember to
subscribe to cz's world for new horrors
every week ring the death bell and
select all notifications and i will see
you in the next one assuming we both
survive
[Music]
jinkies that's impressive